pratique au sein du mime pour en arriver
là il faut savoir que le mime
c'est un organisme un parti politique
structurée et non structurée qui
fonctionnent avec des règles des
principes nous nous sommes engagés dans
une bataille pour un contrat de
mandature
depuis 2015 au niveau de la cité m
avec des organisations et nous avons un
socle qui est solide composée de cinq
organisations
mais c'était pas ma question lui suisse
également comment a été désigné le
candidat la gauche en sélection et
l'intérieur est ce que ça le ferait de
marie jeanne qui s'est auto-désignée
autoproclamé vous savez il ya eu 1 vous
savez nous nous rencontrons je vous ai
dit que le mime et organiser le mieux se
rend compte les pavillons des militants
ont voté pour ces militants et
sympathisants se rencontrent et donc
c'est un avis très favorable au niveau
de notre organisation politique pour que
ce soit en fait l'argent qui conduisait
la liste alors en 2000 le tmb tête -
2022 le mime à a connu une scission on
le sait entre temps une partie des
militants et puis certains dirigeants et
pas des moindres ont quitté le parti se
pose la question de la relève parce que
alfred marie jeanne à nouveau candidat
est ce que ça signifie qu'il n'ya pas de
relève au sein du mime eux parler de
relève la relève
vous savez c'est quelque chose qui
arrive au bon moment au mouvement
c'est où on sent que il faut qu'il ya
une relève donc il faut préparer aussi
la relève à la fois de malchance et a
montré toute sa compétence à gérer à
fédérer donc la relève arrivera quand
vous la préparez vous la préparez on la
voit pas avait il faut réserver des
surprises quand même dites moi
certains parlent évidemment de l'âge du
capitaine cette année donne 85 ans d'âge
alfred marie jeanne je ne voudrais pas
m'attarder sur ce point là
parce qu'on fait en fait durer le temps
fait passer le temps donc il y à méplat
diable en la jeunesse la mer jeunes
l'expérimentation
donc c'est ce que je voulais vous dire
très bien expérience voilà c'est ce que
vous voulez faire parler lucien année
donc je les dis vous êtes également donc
cette conseiller territorial à
l'assemblée de martinique est également
vice-président de la commission
agriculture donc dans cette assemblée de
martinique le bilan concernant la
mandature dans l'agriculture
peut-être mitigé la présidente c'est
nadine renard et au conseil exécutif
c'est monsieur louis boutrin qui est
chargé de l'agriculture
nadine renard a déclaré elle-même lors
d'une séance plénière que ça ne s'est
pas toujours très bien passé avec le
conseiller exécutif en charge des
affaires agricoles et l présidente de la
commission ce que je sais c'est que le
vice-président de la commission
agriculture donc vous même fonctionne et
lucia données fonctionne en parfaite
harmonie parfaite symbiose avec tous les
autres membres de la commission
agriculture là le secteur agricole c'est
un secteur que je connais très bien ce
que j'ai été président de cette
commission à plusieurs reprises alors je
voudrais dire que là le secteur agricole
c'est un secteur pour nous qui est
prioritaire mais qu'est ce que vous avez
fait là pendant les camps les plus
grands vendeurs date et c'est quoi la
mesure emblématique possède un don des
aides qui sont nécessaires au
développement du secteur agricole et
dans l'investissement aides à
l'innovation et de la recherche
donc toutes ces aides à l'accompagnement
des agriculteurs et il y a aussi toute
une série d'outils comme sommes en train
de mettre en place est telle que le
schéma territorial d'irrigation nous
avons aussi vous savez les aussi pour il
ya ce qu'on appelle l
le sar le schéma d'aménagement
management régional qui a été réactivé
quelques et remplacé jerry donc ça n'a
pas tout à fait remplaçant puisque nous
sommes en train de travailler sur un pad
ma voile à dire le projet d'aménagement
et de développement durable lamartine
ont justement oui est ce qu'à travers ce
pas demain vous avez un projet agricole
ambitieux ou et globale pour la
martinique lesage voulait est-ce que
c'est pas un peu de son entourage non
non non c'est pas possible
le ca n'est nos compères ne comportait
pas suffisamment de mesures prescriptive
en matière agricole
on a vu depuis 80 18 plus de mille
hectares de terres agricoles
disparaissent chaque année
donc nous voulons d'un outil aujourd'hui
d'un outil d'aménagement un outil de
développement économique
un outil qui qui est adossé sur des
mesures restrictives vous permettre à
cette agriculture
cela fonctionnait correctement avait
attendait ça c'est un projet que vous
allez intégrer oui mais nous sommes là
pour l'argent mais nous avons commencé à
travailler sur cela
donc voilà au sein de la cité oui oui
vous avez commencé à poser les jalons
oui oui est ce que vous dites ce qu'il
faut comprendre aussi c'est que notre
agriculture aujourd'hui c'est une
agriculture qui doit de répondre aux
attentes des consommateurs
donc voilà ce que je voulais dire oui il
nous reste deux trois minutes à peu près
des missions lucien amené membres du
mime on le rappelle conseiller
territorial de l'assemblée de martinique
et président donc aussi de la régie des
transports de martinique alors de ce
point de vue notamment sur le territoire
de la cacem la rentrée la 2020
2020 2021 la rentrée scolaire je veux
dire en septembre dernier elle s'est
faite
bon il y avait encore un peu
d'ajustements au niveau de
l'organisation du transport sur le
territoire de l'acca scène où en est on
maintenant la fin janvier
ce micro savoir c'est que la réseau sur
le centre le territoire de la cacem
s'améliore progressivement et il faut
que les gens qui nous écoutent le sache
plus d'une trentaine de véhicules neufs
ont été injectés de véhicules avec des
technologies de pointe donc est faisant
le transport sous saint joseph est
entièrement assuré par des bus neufs
autres équipes et huit bus neufs seront
utilisés sur le réseau de shell cherche
à partir de 11 février
les bus acquis par les entreprises et
cherche ses marques du classement arrive
- martinique entre mars et mai les donc
la carte dos c'était obligatoire de
faire ses achats quand il est juste les
buts que nous avons trouvés sur le
réseau centre c'était début ceux qui
étaient venus très vétus vous savez avec
des ce sont des bus qui avait comme une
durée qui existait depuis 14 ans alors
que la limite imposée car nous collons
utilisent des bus de dix ans d'âge donc
c'est ce sont des alors un point aussi
important et très très symbolique dans
l'information voyageur martinique sonos
paul et la régie des transports de
martinique ont retenu l'application qui
sera déployé pour permettre une
information en temps réel des voyageurs
basé sur la géolocalisation des bus est
à dire qu' il faudra que très rapidement
que qu'un usager de la route sache
vraiment quelles sont les anomalies qui
assure sous les voûtes et puis un
dernier point je voulais quand même
ajouter c'est que nous sommes en train
de nous structurer avec les élections
professionnelles qui ont qui est qui ont
été mises en place avec le comité social
et économique c'est une étape importante
dans la situation de la régie puisque
nous disposons désormais un
interlocuteur pour discuter des
questions d'organisation de formation
d'évolution économique de
l'établissement
et puis la gratuité
mais la grâce que vous énoncez
l'allemand tunique transports n'a pas
pris de décision concernant la reprise
de la vente des tickets pour l'instant
cependant il est certain que le roi
réseau va redevenir payant c'est une
question d'équité par rapport aux autres
quoi réseau mais également une
participation des usagers à la
modernisation du transport d'un mois de
février alors rapidement d'accord la
martinique où le sport tout à fait leur
grinta un niveau de service suffisant
pour mettre fin à la gratuité
donc je vois que on avance par étapes et
chaque étape
c'est une avancée significative j'aime
dans la réorganisation et la
modernisation du transport en arctique
une dernière question lucien née de ce
point de vue justement est-ce que vous
travaillez à la liaison entre les
quartiers ruraux et les bourgs alors on
sait que ça commence à se faire pas mal
dans le sud et même dans le nord de la
martinique mais sur la casse m là il ya
encore des choses à faire pour donc
faire des liaisons entre les quartiers
ruraux et les bourgs mais aussi des
liaisons interquartiers que ce soit
saint joseph lamentin fort de france où
il y en a quelques-uns mais c'est pas
suffisant pour que ce soit vraiment ces
réseaux efficaces efficients je sais
transports je sais bien public et même
avant tout le monde
les peaux même les problèmes qui
existent sur les réseaux de transport
non je suis à l'écouté de tout le monde
et nous y travaillons nous faisons nous
allons faire en sorte qu'un autre au
classement soit un transport non
seulement non seulement parce que pour
éviter les embouteillages
je suis mais pour m justement je sais
c'est il faut faire suer un train de
vous dire que nous sommes avec lequel
nous avons mis en place le terme houda
les termes modalités
maintenant notre nous allons travailler
a reçu au lecteur opérationnalité c'est
à dire quelqu'un peut passer d'un monde
à un autre monde et avec un même ticket
découvrir parfois toute la martinique
vers tous les réseaux
donc voilà cssc ça ne soit souhaitons
que soient évitées en application dans
le pays
le sien année merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions c'est moi qui vous
remercie
bonne journée vous
mehdi minne et assez
[Musique]